[Music]
yeah for those of you wondering there
was a big rumor going on that the show
had ended I know it is not true I'm here
to say that Robin and I were very upset
not Fred doesn't even know but does
nothing I'm going on yeah at the
funniest morning I was talking to JD and
I heard some it's very you know you
gotta ask JD ten times what's going on
but he was explaining me that Richard
had invited him to a Swedish death metal
concert and JD cause he doesn't speak
clearly he was like a guru so I was like
why you go and then I got like it took
me a while to figure out that he was
invited but then according to Richard at
the Swedish death metal concerts a lot
of the audience gets into a thing that
looks like one of those old ships where
they chained you and then they make you
row really and Richard was really
excited to get JD in there in the boat
to simulate rowing a boat can you
imagine how long it took me
JD do I have that right see like you
didn't understand don't know what the
band's name is I don't know what just
happened can you tell that same story
again until we understand it make it
like Groundhog Day where you just keep
telling the same thing over and over
again tomorrow I still don't know that
every day
say it again I want to say like 20 times
mana Mars Amon Amarth talking to JD
puppet JD puppet what's the name of the
band
Paro yeah burn stronger part of our farm
compound I know my gang I just figured
it out I didn't know why he invited you
to a Swedish heavy metal concert I
realize you're speaking Swedish younger
Bartow to Richard's like really excited
to get JD to row this boat I don't even
understand what happens like in other
words the audience sits in a boat so
there's no boat in the crowd the boat is
onstage I see a Viking ship because they
sing about Viking stuff right the crowd
sits on the floor right and pretends to
row and they're all in a row and it
looks cool as hell oh there's a [__]
song rule twilight of the Thunder God
oh my god Avery I'm [__] getting
chills right now
what's that JD puppet why do you want to
get you on the floor rowing oh it's a
blast is it listen when Johann comes in
and sing
oh this is Yama
it's good
so front rises from the way
birds JD go JD puppy Wow
Man Overboard randomizer
what was the show that you were in I was
in a play called one man to government
that was the play where you brought
Donald Trump up that's right right yeah
yeah usually I bring people up from the
yard every night we would bring people
up on stage and I would get them to move
something for me on stage there's like a
big trunk so the night that you brought
it to New York
we heard that Trump was in and almost
every night in that play there was
someone incredible in the audience but
you can't bring their puppet them up on
stage it's disrespectful you can't bring
up and win Wilder you Tom Hanks you
can't it's the you absolutely Justin oh
no well I know I'd be terribly
embarrassed
exactly and I'd be embarrassed to do
that to such a person however Donald and
I said to Holly I was like Donald Trump
is the only person but love we can bring
onstage I said because half the audience
don't really like him anyway right so we
either win with everybody or we win with
half the audience and listen before he
ran way before right before this in 2012
okay so I said if it's not going great
I'm gonna bring him up and we were like
that's it okay I'll be fine amazing
night yeah and then it was one of those
days of biblical reign for an hour in
New York in the summer the heavens just
opened which always makes for a bad show
because people are so hang on their
knees are wet I don't want to be here
and want to be snuggled up at home
anyway it's not it's not a great
audience and this is now show 425 and I
think [__] it I'm just like I know where
he was about halfway back on the aisle
is she with Melania yeah and I grabbed
his arm yeah and I said you're coming
with me
he laughs no no he laughed and he came
up and the audience goes wild and I
started saying I need you to move this
this is a thing called manual labor
you'll have never done this before
no yeah and I saw it and I moved him
around and I fired him and all things
like this and it was fun but here's the
thing I remember most about it when the
people would go off I'd get them to move
this trunk and take it into the wings
out of this door and then our stage
manager would stand with the people and
he and they'd often be a bit
shell-shocked that they were just on
stage and he'd say that you did great it
was fantastic wait here
Cheng's is going to call you back you'll
walk across the stage and back to your
seat you
great right and I said to our stage
rounder I said what was he like in the
wings and [__] you know
I promise you this was the response he
went it was like he thought he was the
President of the United States he went
round shaking everybody's hand in the
wings but not in a genuine way in a this
is a big deal for you yeah this is a big
deal for you
to shake my hand here but no one had
ever done that no and you can't argue
with the charisma of the man because to
his credit he goes up and people are
laughing by the end huge cheer because
what a great sport you know it's all in
a sense he went over the audience that
night at the show yeah I think he did
what I know so I think the audience felt
like ah what a treat you know that they
saw something that they knew was real
that wasn't you know what I mean and and
also he wasn't running to be the
president United States he was the host
of The Apprentice
[Music]
[Applause]
and worry you know Tracy Morgan I love
the guy he's always on our show he
bought another new car that's brand new
run why is this car two million dollars
and what is that why why in other words
what car could be justifiably two
million dollars and why well it's
handmade first of all the car and by
handmade you mean that guys like bang
out the engine and by hand well it
usually means one guy yeah well it's
more than one guy I mean it's a couple
of guys but they'd but the thing is a
separate job to do on the car how much
when they build it but it's hit the car
is handmade it's not like it goes to an
assembly line when you say hey I made
how far do they go with that like in
other words so they have a guy forging
out like the metal and yeah oh yeah you
mean like metal yeah and they make them
making the seats you know everything you
know they got the leather they saw it
they do it exactly in its special
leather it comes from special cows and
yeah
all right thanks romba no problem yeah
what's up Frank
Frank from Florida Robin hey Dad you
know I know Ron is your go-to guy for
cars and car questions I've never heard
somebody the radio know less about cars
oh yeah I need a limo driver what did he
get wrong it's just clueless
you asked about their you know banging
sheet metal out hand by hand to put
these cars together yeah yeah yeah yeah
like she's just ridiculous you know
lessons on cars so Ronnie doesn't know
what he's talking about by cars
you are so full of [__] dude why you're
out of your mind man they're hand-built
but it's not they're not understand
belie but they're no one's banging out a
blender for a Bugatti I mean that your
molding the actual body and everything
which is done by one or two different
people what the [__] are you talking
about that's about what he asked you
that's not the question he asked you
Ronnie you can see is this usual I'm not
confused as usual he's saying Ronnie
you're wrong about the book whatever
he's right because he says he's right
maybe Frank will be my new expert go
[__] Frank : Fred who's right these
cars are hand built these cars take I
think at least a month they even problem
what does that mean how far do we go and
we're handling and I know there's two
guys that build the engine and they
probably do it we're not in Game of
Thrones milord however assembling it by
hand which means they probably have put
wrenches on it and they're talking at
all it's not a machine that's doing that
correct and that's what I said [__] no
I didn't say that [__] I said they
molded the body they mold out the body
you jerk off how is the body made then
he'll run the bodies are made all the
same that's it there's no they're not no
they're not no no no gather nice cars
not one car is exactly the same
absolutely we do
yeah go [__] yourself you don't matter
no do you know the guys who build the
car yeah you know the guys who build the
car one guy his name is boo any other
guy's name is God he get it boo
why did JD cancel your car show no idea
do you want to take away Ronnie show
permanent you can't is Ronnie cancel the
[__] show I'm sorry sorry what no
means he's sorry what shows cancelled
they should have kept this new doesn't
know what he's [__] talking about you
have to ask JD JD
put the hammer down and had no problem
with it
[Music]
in other words all that other [__]
you can do without the fight you like
yeah I wouldn't want to hear that either
right did you call it quote the most
boring a show ever
can you revamp the show and bring it
back you know what it is I think he
needs me there with him to just keep him
on track with arguing and then he needs
Fred there is Fred Ronnie racecar you
[__] maybe what I'm thinking of doing
is now that the company owns Pandora I
might do an hour podcast it's me and
Ronnie and the Fred Ronnie and we just
take our questions would you listen to
that absolutely
[Music]
Gnarls Barkley yeah baby you sing it
beautiful boy son this guy
[Music]
it's up there high that's high that
guy's name again he was a judge on The
Voice or something again from gnarls
Barkley's no yeah
CeeLo CeeLo CeeLo green
CeeLo green yeah who do you sing it
right yeah see if I can get up there
[Music]
just me
perfect what a talent I am
[Music]
what I was curious about with carpool
karaoke is you wouldn't answer who the
best carpool karaoke guest was isn't
that true you in other words you avoided
saying who the very best was well it's
not but I could say who my favorite was
my my favorite for sure all my car yeah
you know I understand why the Paul
McCartney one would be your your I mean
a guy from England and you probably
worship the Beatles as much as I do
yeah it's just mind-blowing that you're
sitting there doing let it be in
Liverpool in Liverpool yeah with Paul
McCartney cried yeah it was emotional
know what happened I couldn't believe
that I was I remember when I was doing
it thinking I don't know what I've done
to deserve such memories I don't know
what I don't know what has gone right
that I would that I would have such
memories all of it everything the show
the Tonys but like there in Liverpool I
think as we you know there was like some
jetlag involved in you you're flying and
then we got up to Liverpool and and then
we're there and we're doing it and I
just had this overwhelming feeling of
like my my grandfather was a musician
who I'm pretty sure introduced the
Beatles to me and with with my dad at
the time and just had this overwhelming
feeling of like this if he could see
this if he could just get the Opera he
had the opportunity to shake the man's
hand it would have made his week is
month is year and here are my singing
these very songs and it just I couldn't
help it you came I could it over whelmed
me in the whole moment and the the
brilliance of the man of paul was when i
said to him and i was shocked by it i'm
not someone who's like so quick to be
that emotional he driving around is just
me and him in a car and i didn't expect
that he said that's the power of music
and i and i said to my if my grandad was
here he'd get a real kick out of this
and he just when he is like and before
that he told a story which i hadn't
heard before of how let it be counting
that he'd had this vision of his of his
mother mary
saying just let it be let it light and
the whole thing you're like I don't know
I've never I'd heard the phrase I
stopped traffic before and I'd never
really understood it until like walking
down Penny Lane with sapore McCartney
and every single car at the junction is
stopped and you cannot hear a single
horn
no one is beeping their horn because
they're just going oh my god yeah
unbelievable you're like this is madness
[Music]
hi Shawn you're on the air
they're giving me a radio show and
nightly talk show I would love for you
to share with me any sort of wisdom this
is the first time I'm going on the air
you know I should offer him JD first
show because JD's gold cuz imagine when
you get on with this JD I understand you
won't work for the Howard Stern Show or
some way my ratings are going through
the roof people can't believe what
they're hearing if you don't mind me
asking you that well but is it true you
spend $10,000 on webcam girls what do
you think is that a is that a home run
or what this is brilliant
can't wait to talk to you tonight man
yeah three years I didn't wash my chr
well you got only got to do say how is
it for three years you didn't wash your
sheets the story here Sean when he's a
guest on your show
ask him didn't my strew through your
pants in the closet
burning through your pants JD if you
want to do a comedy show here's your guy
yeah I mean who lays on the floor
I don't hide there's a cloud and then
cockroaches stole my couch
oh here's a good one Shawn just say to
him so Jake real JD why did you reveal
your engagement on Twitter instead of on
Howard Stern Show you work for the
Howard Stern Show and you gave that
exclusive to Twitter go ahead I'm King
no why don't you wait for tomorrow's
great that's radio gold my friend I'm
asking you now so they can in ten hours
from now
oh you know it's Sean interview him
about when JD said Seinfeld was
Letterman's best guest and not me
tweeted that you know who is Lauren's
best guess
yeah sure go ahead I see a really great
guest yeah I don't want it I don't want
to say anything so go ahead JD you said
fine but whatever you do don't ask JD
about his finances because here's the
answer you'll get you hear this KD
$6,000 oh now that's radius if you get
JD on this is Brady up gold that's right
you got to ask him when you're on the
air with him how he almost drowned from
a water slide at a theme park in two
feet of water
are you willing going this guy show or
no
[Music]
Chris we used to be really good friends
with Ralph now they're going at each
other over social media are they they're
having a Twitter war yeah like Chris was
really close to Ralph yeah and now
Ralph's curse was out Chris on Twitter
but so ridiculous Chris wrote whatever I
said Ralph sounds like it really stuck
with you and then Ralph wrote turncoat
Chris wrote for the record all I said
was we went to a bad restaurant this is
vicious Ralph goes thanks for commenting
dummy but not really whatever you said
was worse what's going on Chris real
quick like what happened it just blew up
you follow Ralph right yeah I should
give you some context because our main
show account our Twitter account tweeted
out an old video of Mamet and Ralph's
going at it right and it was I mean my
met you know to be fair was very vicious
to Ralph right like a 60 year old idiot
who dyes his hair horrible stuff Ralph
you're not old you're not uncool you're
a six year old man you dye your hair
bleach blonde that is the epitome of
being a cool person I tweeted out and
said by the way lest you think I said
anything like that all I said is we went
to a bad restaurant together
what Mamet did was vicious so his
response was to that he said what you
did Chris was so much worse than the met
because you and I were friends
Oh which was you you did more than just
say we went to a bad restaurant you said
Ralph was annoying at the rest he was
annoying and and bitched about the
different places we went to I didn't
compare him like my method to Harvey
Weinstein and Bill Cosby right I just
think there's a bit of a difference and
I don't know why he is so sensitive to
what I'm saying so you don't call him
anymore and you're not friends with him
anymore
I mean you know it was a beautiful
weekend last weekend and the weekend
before I would have loved to have gone
out we lived down the street from each
other and done something but I just
didn't feel comfortable right reaching
out to him he's on the deal yeah yeah
what a shame
yeah it's I feel he's going through
something and I don't know what it is
and I feel like he's projecting whatever
anger or whatever angst he's going
through on me I say and it's unfair
the guy on Jeopardy lost his name
Holzhauer
yeah James house an hour no James Halton
power house impossible awesome father
James Hasselhoff so uh first of all
Richard such a weirdo Richard Christie
who works for us he cried when the guy
lost he's got problems he's so weird he
doesn't know this man will came to me
and he said Richard's going around
scratching his bald head and he's like
making a hole in it and then it turns
out Richard had a spider crawling on him
and thought it would be interesting to
see the spider crawl on him and then he
lost track of the spider and now he goes
I know the spiders not on my head but I
keep feeling like it is and I keep
scratching my head
first of all a he was crying during
Jeopardy and B he allowed his spider to
crawl on him tell his story last night a
spider was crawling across my shirt and
you just and you were like hey I just
want him to crawl on me for a while yeah
I didn't bother him I was just kind of
looking at it I was like I'm not scared
of spiders I am I would have freaked out
and then it just crawled and went inside
my shirt and then I couldn't find it and
now you think it's on your head it's
probably in my mind that I'm like now a
little weird feeling why did you just
shower and get rid of the whole oh now
that would be - I will eventually yeah
you're scratching your head again yeah
as you feel the spider on it's in my
mind I imagine but it could be on me
sure it was a real spider yeah it was
definitely real yeah but my biggest
fight it's probably eating the other
bugs that are on me so that's good yeah
but I mean it's really weird it's like
it's like you're in a hormone and why
did you cry when the guy in jeopardy
oh my god my wife I both we were you
guys found each other oh we love James
like he's like the frickin Michael
Jordan of Jeopardy and yeah but he's not
cuz he didn't get the Robin Jennings is
the Michael Jordan he's the LeBron yeah
but but tell Robin your theory see
everyone's running around with the
theory about this guy and I just think
he lost the guy who watches bugs crawl
across this shirt I know there's so many
things that rant in my head because it's
like so weird that he would
is right before he beat Ken Jennings you
would want to put out the theory that he
didn't want to be Ken Jennings I might
have you don't remember that including a
spider exactly I hear I hear a new
theory every second and I'm like okay
that could be true what is it Gary
this morning in our meeting you said you
wanted to lose because he was tired and
he didn't want to be Kenny's record no I
said I had heard people say that that
maybe he was tired and wanted to go home
well Joe may be good now so you just
said that Richard on the Internet
oh there's oh my god there's so many
three John Hines theory though John has
a theory that jeopardy rigged it so that
they knew that this woman was a really
excellent player yes so they held her
back from playing until right until this
guy was about to beat Ken Jennings why
don't they want him to beat Ken Jennings
what is their attachment to Ken yes John
this is a [__] nutty theory my
thought is that when it got to the Ken
Jennings money thing they would put him
up against the best contestant they had
and think okay if he beats her then he
deserves it yeah when you look at her 27
year old librarian wrote a master's
thesis on Jeopardy and why the clues are
in certain places they knew she was
going to be really really good and so I
don't think it was fixed that he was
going to lose but I do think they said
all right we're gonna put up our best
against him to see if he could break the
record well that makes more sense than
anything else I've heard I had heard too
that some of the Jeopardy writers like
weren't happy with the way James played
because he wouldn't go in the right way
they say a lot of people from now on are
gonna play two of the daily doubles he
only got one I guess is on the phone
guys the Spyder in Richards brain so he
went in through your ear now he's in
your head
I'm gonna lay my eggs
[Laughter]
[Music]
let's see first of all let me just say
to you I love you first I love you too
and Leslie West is my hero he was the
first guy I wrote this on one of his
albums he asked me to write a few words
but he was one of the first guys that I
ever you know in rock'n'roll who I
really related to I thought his band
mountain was incredible when they came
on the scene I got to tell you something
and this is my point
having Leslie on today as we make our
move to satellite you are my first guest
that I want to do this with I want to
say to you thank you for all the years
of coming in always appearing live with
us always
playing playing for us my pleasure man
because you are absolutely and my hero
and this is the next step I mean you
just think you do things right but I
want you to know that this show
appreciates you I personally appreciate
you in the music you've given the world
and you're a great guy you're a survivor
and I love that and you're a really good
guy good guy to hang with and this show
appreciates all the contributions you've
made over the years I think this song is
very fitting bye next down this mountain
does Dylan I picked some great songs and
it's we rated all right
[Music]
hey I'm in a row must a man walk down
give on the car in May
[Music]
how many seas must a rider
sail
before she sleeps in the same
[Music]
how many time most cannonballs fly
you for the forever
[Music]
my friend winters and blow away
he has a mouth my man
[Music]
the answer isn't
I love you man I love you I love you
that's great you always give me the
chills when you play and sing man and
not too many people can do that you are
this you are awesome i swatched the
segment with you
skydiving with Tom Cruise yeah I thought
you were completely out of your mind
I mean you will do anything for that
show and Tom Cruise by the way it looks
like he's skydives like on a regular
everyday basis yeah it's incredible to
be around him his Spirit and energies I
would have said you know and this is it
I love my TV show and I'm drawing the
[__] line I am NOT jumping out of
plane with time is that something you
really wanted to do or you just felt
like hey I got a man up and do this I
just thought actually all of that comes
back to the notion of going and not
going to be doing this forever right so
now is the time when we stop we'll go
[__] look what we did look what we
did in that amount of time and jumping
out of a plane with Tom Cruise and like
and you know what people don't see is
like they're the man-hours from the team
on our show oh my god we did two jumps
to sort of film it right somebody
back-to-back I didn't know that we did
back-to-back jumps and Tom did a jump
before I got there to just work now no
to work out the plotting of the and he's
incredible Tom prepped the guy I was
gonna jump with he interviewed five
people bring herself on the phone to
pick who he felt was the best person for
me to jump with what was the whole story
though I didn't understand it you know
you met him somewhere and you want to
remind the show and you know but then he
had to give you his phone number no well
what happened was I am Thomas we have a
great relationship with Tom on the show
right we've like recreated his entire
film career we did a stupid thing in
London where I had had an idea for a new
business called a cruise boat on the
River Thames called Tom's cruise on the
river James Corden right and and then
his publicist got in touch and said he
was being honored with a big film makers
award in Vegas would I go and and host
it as a surprise and that's absolutely
of course I'm sure
so I went up I did it and he was amazing
he gave the most eloquent speech and
after the show tom said ah thank you so
much James
are you gonna come to this thing I said
I've gotta fly back and he said well
look you know you know stay in touch
give me a call and I said I said tie
some tongue I said really lovely but I
don't have your phone yeah how do you
know and yeah you do are in the honesty
I don't you went I'll get it to you
I went Tom you don't have to I know I
said to him I said I know you're not
lying I know that you mean this but
don't worry about it and you're not
gonna call him anybody anyway it was
like I'll get you my number I was like
you won't but this has been great yeah
yeah so we leave and we got laughing and
joking two days later my assistant came
into office and said can you you've got
to go down to conference from one or
whatever and I went in and in conference
room one was a massive amount of
balloons that said thank you and a box
and I opened the box and there was a
cake in the shape of a telephone with
all of these symbols odd symbols on the
on the dial of an old rotary dial
telephone and then in an envelope was a
dictaphone and it said press play so I
press play and it says your mission
should you choose to accept it is to
work out the code and call the number on
your cell phone
the
message will self-destruct in five
seconds and then it way
don't-don't-don't so I sit on my own in
this conference room trying to figure
out what number correlates to what thing
and now I think I've worked it out I
called once it said it was just going
mmm booze I got it wrong I changed two
numbers I called and this first one
hello I went is that Tom Cruise and he
went is that James Corden I said yeah he
went well now you've got my number
Wow sure this is amazing now that's a
thank you for doing that for him because
because he put time and effort into this
thing so much effort yeah I mean Tom
Cruise do that but he did sure
[Music]
the Howard Stern Show